[Music]
today we welcome back Eric Wilson a
former martial arts expert of over 24
years a nation built on Protestant
values America has now become saturated
with spiritualism and Eastern mysticism
through mindful meditation Eastern
philosophy Martial Arts taii yoga Reiki
and traditional Chinese medicine
Christians and non-believers alike are
subtly indoctrinated into the
pantheistic religions of the Far East
however the scriptures do warn us know
ye not that your body is a temple of God
brother Eric welcome back it's good to
be here again thank you well let's start
unpacking this experience that you've
had as it relates to the scripture I
just read growing up as a Christian I
had heard this verse you know we are the
temple of God but I didn't take it
literally uh so often we don't really
believe that it's sort of just a
phrase what I found though is from the
Bible
as well as from other inspired
writings God dwells inside of each of us
through his word that's right so in like
Romans chapter 6: 16 it says don't you
realize that who you yield yourself a
servant to obey that's whose servant you
become that's your master that's right
so if I yield to God's word God's spirit
comes into me Jesus said the words I
speak unto you they are spirit and life
but if I'm yielding to the instructions
of martial arts or Eastern Mystics or
any kind of new age or occult when I
yield I'm opening that door for those
spirits to come in and be active in my
life now many people are Skeptics they
say martial arts is just a form of
benign exercise yes tell me if that's
true I I want to show you and and on on
the documentary we have many quotes I
just want to show you two quotes now our
viewers don't know which documentary
you're you want to go ahead and tell us
a bit about it okay on the docu that we
did with little light Studios a number
of years ago it's called the dragon
revealed um on that series we actually
show many quotes from martial arts
Masters but today I just have time I
just want to show two quotes all right
let's start okay the first quote
actually is from a Grandmaster named
gichin fukushi he says Spiritual
Development is Paramount technical
skills are merely a means to the end
this is from a 10th on he is known as
the father of modern day karate another
gentleman Robert James barate says Zen
offers an interesting perspective in the
world of martial arts and
spirituality because it becomes hard to
see where the spiritual philosophy ends
and the Marshall practice begins so
there is definitely a blend you can't
have one without the other there's no
way to separate it you cannot separate
the two so where do these I mean where
does this actually lead Okay so we're
the temple and then we go into these
yoga and martial arts studios and could
we consider those temples as well yes I
want to show uh I want to show a
photograph of where martial arts began
okay uh it's at the Shaolin Temple in
Hunan Province of China all the martial
arts in the world find their Origins
there and a lot of people don't realize
but the the Shaolin Temple was
originally a Hindu temple so all of its
roots came from India and all of India's
Roots have come from Egypt hermetica yes
yes so so there's a good line that's
just traveling through history and
transforming ACC according to our our
culture and our time yes Satan just
repackages the same lies as what he told
Adam and Eve in the Garden of Eden
Master deceiver yes so in that in that
photograph which I'm going to let them
show now that we're looking at of the
Shaolin Temple there's something
interesting in that photograph
you see all of these monks coming out of
the temple and they are holding an
orange or a Golden Globe and orb in
their hand and this Photograph I had
actually purchased a book from The
Shaolin Temple that the first
Grandmaster I was under had recommended
and when I saw this picture I was like
what are they doing I mean they're not
holding swords or spears or any kind of
fighting techniques what are they doing
and I turned the page over and there was
a description in the chin chines
language and underneath of it it had
been translated into English M and it
shocked me what that picture actually
said it said Chan Buddhism into all the
world ah so what the Shaolin Temple
their entire goal martial arts was just
a means to the end their purpose was to
take Chan which is what the Chinese call
it or Zen is what the japanes call it
that Buddhism into all the world they
are Evangelical exactly so your
instructor is actually a military arm of
a religion that is then making disciples
of everyone yes I yeah I could see the
parallel there because in yoga and
Eastern meditation there's also another
word for Zen which is Prana yes and it's
all about taking your so-called breath
and using it to exalt yourself and to
unite with the universal God yes right
and what what's what's amazing to me is
there's so much emphas empis on breath
in the martial arts and in yoga and in
taii and in Chinese Kong and a lot of
people don't realize why by doing the
deep breathing exercises and the rituals
that they promote it actually causes the
brain to enter an altered state of
consciousness and what happens is it
shuts down the frontal lobe your
critical thinking and when that happens
the brain becomes an open doorway for
Spiritual influences not just from God
but from the devil and his fall angels
Supernatural indeed yes yes I want to
show a quote now from a sholin master
that came here to the United States he
actually opened a school in New York
City and I've never been there but my
wife has and I want to show just what he
said this is from an interview that was
done with him it says Xiang Ming says
that Chan or Zen philosophy is simple
that it is heart to heart and mind to
mind he then says he never tries to
change others beliefs Xiang Ming wants
everybody to have an open heart that
means an open mind right that means take
down the guard right he wants everyone
to have an open heart and to respect
their own body as a
temple when I it's it's the same gospel
but flipped upside down it's like the
gnosticism that we've seen coursing
through through media and if you look at
the picture of xiong Ming he's standing
in his daang his Studio his school there
in New York look at the symbol that's
behind him it's a dragon so if he says
my students their body is being designed
as a temple a temple for who for the
spirit of the dragon and we know from
Revelation 12 that's Satan we do indeed
Xiang Ming goes on and says let go of
ego man maintain perspective and let the
mind be free and and flexible well we
also hear that in in Psycho Babble that
comes from Young and you know the
philosophers it's not a coincidence no
the ego that he's talking about there is
speaking about the identity of the
individual who you are who you identify
yourself as so that's what all of the
Eastern mysticism its whole goal is to
make you non-d duel where you don't
identify yourself as an IND idual that
you become one with the universe one
with the the universal Consciousness and
the same happens in you know yoga it's
ego death they constantly talk about
that and so as a yogi you go in and your
whole aim is how do I get rid of this
how do I stop being this way how do I
you know have this ego death and you you
also find that when they do uh drugs you
know yes um iwaska and different things
like this the whole point is to kill
obliterate the identity that God gave
you in the Chinese martial arts they
actually have at higher levels they have
something where they call silencing the
chattering monkey the chattering monkey
is who they say that voice that you hear
in your head all the time you want to
get rid of that which is the voice God
gave us right a conscience a conscience
and it's also even your own thoughts
they want to get rid of that and they
say when you get rid of that then you
start becoming enlightened because
you're a blank slate and they can write
upon whatever they choose right I want
to show uh I want to show you another
quot quote this is from a Grandmaster
named M soyama he was a Japanese
Grandmaster 10th Dawn his nickname was
called the god hand because he could
kill full-grown male bulls with one
punch incredible um but I want to show
you because a lot of people they still
they still struggle to understand that
you can't separate the physical from the
spiritual side of it okay in this quote
he says the man who wants to walk the
way of karate
cannot afford to neglect Zen and
spiritual training and Jesus tells us
that he is the way the truth and the
life and he is the word of God so Zen is
another way and they all believe that if
you follow that way just like in
Hinduism or any of the other you know
ancient uh Pagan religions they say you
still achieve godhood you still make it
to Heaven there's no wrong path you can
be murderous right could be a thief you
could do whatever it takes but you're
still holy because the God is already
within you that's right and you just
have to awaken that you have to have
your eyes open through these practices
so that you know what they say that you
are a
God so one of the questions I know a lot
of people have asked is what is Zen you
know when I was growing up you didn't
hear about Zen but now it's like you go
to Target or you go into any housewares
you know shop or trinket store and
you'll see Buddha statues and little
emblems with Zen or find your Zen and
this kind of milk or this kind of coffee
and even if you're not exposed to actual
Mar martial arts they have you know
cartoons for kids Master Shifu you know
Kung Fu Panda and all these things and
the kids are themselves being trained up
so a lot of people they they they wonder
what does zen mean I mean we sort of
think oh it means peace and happiness
but I want to show you what they
actually say this is a quote um from
Hindu and Buddhist sources it says the
term Chan which is Chinese or Zen which
is Japanese originates from the Hindu
Sanskrit language the word meaning da
which literally means meditation yes so
the Chinese have M moving meditation in
taii or in their forms that they do in
in kung fu the Japanese have moving
medit ation in the C that they do in
their
forms it says the this form of
meditation is described as a lucid
awareness said to be achieved through
focusing on a single object for a
prolonged period of time this is similar
to the training that I received when I
was taking up yoga you know the eight
limbs of yoga yes and the meditation is
such a a key part of getting you to
shift Your Allegiance from God the
Creator to God of of Satan really the
The Serpent and there's a lot of serpent
worship that goes on I wanted to Circle
back though because we talked briefly
about Prana yes is this the same as Chi
yes Chi and Kei and Prana and there's
another word in Europe that was
developed called Oregon energy I haven't
heard that um vibrational energy free
it's all the same thing and it's become
a part of our vernacular we're always
saying oh that that guy has Good Vibes
or yeah you know your vibration is too
low it's it's just yeah prevalent now
what what they've done is they've made
it a pantheistic god like to the to the
dowst the Chinese Dost the yin andong is
a symbol of the Dao which is said to
symbolize or stand for what they call
God but it's a pantheistic God right
they say that God is in the Rock it's in
the tree it's in every human being it's
in every animal when I was in the
martial arts I can remember after black
belt level you know The Grandmaster
would would have the black belts come
out and we would go out and stand they
called it tree hugging but you would
stand in a keyong stance and you'd put
your hands in a certain position and
your feet in a certain position and arch
your back and you would visualize uh the
energy moving through the channels the
governing you know vessel and the
conception vessel and you would try to
absorb this Chi energy from the tree so
it's really a spirit yes yes the last
Grandmaster that I was under finally
opened that up he said to the beginner
we tell him it's Inner Strength you know
to an intermediate we tell them it's
breath he said but to a disciple we
reveal its Spirit the truth the truth
now in yoga we also have what's called
samade I should say I shouldn't say we
anymore but as a you know yes a teacher
at that time that was something that we
our goal was samati break that down for
us okay well I'm going to show you this
from a a quote from them um samade is
actually a Hindu word that means an
intense concentration that is achieved
through meditation at which point a
union with the Divine is said to be
achieved yoking yoking which is what the
word yoga means but the scary thing is
is when you see you know Japanese or
Chinese you know Masters or even
students and they're doing they're
seated in a Lotus position and they're
meditating and they're saying om and
they're breathing and they're focusing
all of that is to open the mind to take
down the guard and to allow something
else to get in so it's a form of a a
seance it's a ritual yes and it's an
incantation to invite the inhabitation
of the spirit within you that's exactly
and that's the union that's exactly
right and it it takes a process you know
some people they can get it in a few
years other people it might take 10 15
20 years but that is the entire goal is
a union with this pantheistic God that
they call the da
the other dichotomy of this is that you
know we don't do our research we just
trust and we go with the flow go with
the flow you hear that constantly said
and repeated when you're in classes
whether it's martial art arts or or yoga
uh let's talk about whether or not a
Christian can do these practices and
still serve
Christ Jesus says why do you call me
Lord Lord and yet do not the things that
I say the word Lord in HEB Hebrew
actually is Adonai it means Sovereign
King how can you call me your king but
you won't obey
me if the martial arts is telling us to
do something that God's word tells us
the opposite we have to make a choice am
I going to serve this master or am I
going to serve another so no you can't
if Jesus said turn the cheek and martial
art says block encounter if Jesus says
don't bow to someone else and martial
arts says bow to your Sensei bow to your
seafu bow to your opponent um we're
automatically choosing to obey the voice
of the serpent instead of obeying the
voice of God so how high did you yield
to the opposing God
here
um I wanted I wanted rank you know when
I made black belt um I was the fifth
person in 30 years I Remember The
Grandmaster came to me and he said you
know Eric he said what do you want to do
now it took 14 years to get to that
point he said what do you want now and I
looked at him and I said I want what you
have cuz he could do things that were
Supernatural so you made an idol out of
your seafu yes and I made and you were
Covetous I actually made an idol out of
the martial arts I wanted the ability I
wanted the power that I saw did you
receive power yes tell us a little bit
about
that different people in martial arts
Express or they manifest the gifts of
this chi in different ways um I remember
the the first Grandmaster I was training
under one day he was in there teaching a
class and he he was telling this person
how to hit and strike this this heavy
bag it was like a 75 or 80 PB heavy bag
and you know you could tell the young
man was you know trying his best and
when I say young man he was in his 20s
or or early 30s and I remember the
grandmas went over and he grabbed it
with his left hand the bag a leather bag
and he lifted it up with one hand and he
shook it this thing was 75 or 80 lbs he
said that's the kind of power you've got
to have and you know and everybody that
was there in the studio that day they
were just like wow did you see that we
had other men that I had trained under
um where they would break coconuts you
know with two fingers you know a h a
coconut is harder than the human skull
they'd set it up there they could smack
it two fingers with two fingers and
shatter the coconut I see children when
they're Gra graduating or there's sort
of like a performance that they put on
for their parents to come and see how
they're you know progressing in in their
martial arts I've seen them break boards
and cylinder blocks is that smoke and
mirrors or is that power sometimes it's
smok and mirrors uh if you see somebody
and they've got like five boards or
they've got six boards and there's a
pencil in between each board there's
some physical strength that's necessary
but there's also um mechanical so the
physics take over and it gives you the
appearance that you have power and then
you start to identify with that and seek
it but on the real side there's men that
take their hands and they can shatter
cinder blocks I mean you go up out in
the backyard and grab a cinder block and
they take their palm and just smack it
and shatter it is it actually them or is
it something else it's the spirit that's
in them and it's it's actually there's
a one of the questions that came to my
mind when I was in martial arts because
I did did Chinese martial arts but I
also had a first-degree black belt in
seven Styles and some of those styles
were Japanese or or
okan and in the the okan system of
karate
do I asked the instructor one time I
said what does karate mean he said it
means empty hand I was like oh you know
I get to use my hands as weapons instead
of holding a weapon but then we trained
with tonas we trained with swords we
trained with bow staffs we trained with
knives and I was like and nunchuck and I
was like wait a minute I thought this
was empty hand why are we training with
weapons and it was not until after I
made discipleship that the light came on
and I shouldn't say that it was it was a
demon that was just allowing me it's
time to give him this information the
secret knowledge yes the reason that
it's called empty hand is because for me
to you know if you tell me Eric would
you hand me you know that that plant and
I reached for it my mind had to tell my
hand to reach for that when I empty my
hand that means my mind is becoming
empty another mind directs my hand what
to do so empty hand it was not simply
just no weapons it means you're empty in
yourself that's why they teach you to
empty your mind is so another mind can
take possession so when that happens
it's not your hand anymore because a
demon goes into your hand and your hand
can become like a piece of lead mhm I
have seen you know just some
extraordinary examples of this power
that they have where they will punch
within like an inch of your chest and
and actually cause your heart to stop
yes yes I there's no law that could expl
that there there's no physical law that
that can do that it's only a spiritual
event that causes that it's a spiritual
power that is causing that just like
moso Yama when he would punch a full
grown bull there's no way that any human
being could punch a bull and drop it
Dead with one punch that was a spirit a
demon that was causing that event to
take place because he had yielded
himself over and over and over again for
so many years and the the more you yield
the more power is given to you so again
what's the endgame for this whole
process why take on this spiritual
form the endgame is to connect man with
god with what they call God which is not
it's demons it's evil Spirits there's a
lot of symbology that they use symbols
that I've seen in yoga that I've seen
even in you know uh Hitler's regime yes
the scha and when I was in India the
scha was actually kind of reversed yes
the direction even the word Aryan for
them they said it came from us so the
movement itself of you know what Hitler
did was satanic and spiritual nature it
wasn't just
racism it's funny because the first time
that the light that that the warning
Bells started sounding I remember we
were sitting at an advanced class it was
late at night and The Grandmaster had
gotten a videotape from The Shaolin
Monks in China and it showed them out on
this field they were doing a
demonstration for the Chinese people and
you know how like when the when you have
a football game and at halftime the band
goes out and they'll March PP and show
and they'll make shapes yes and you go
oh that's so neat I remember seeing all
these Shaolin Monks marching and doing
these shapes and they did a schwacha and
I was sitting there and I was probably a
green belt or a brown belt wasn't black
belt yet and I was looking and I thought
what does Hitler have to do with the
Shaolin Temple what do they do in awasa
so this I didn't have any clue but then
the longer that I was in it I started
seeing the pentagram that's a Hindu and
Buddhist symbol the schwacha is a
Buddhist and Hindu symbol the hexagram
the six-pointed star is a Hindu and
Buddhist symbol all of these people even
Hitler Adolf Hitler they said he kept a
copy of a a book called The Secret
Doctrine from Madame HP bobowski it was
beside his bed every night he wanted
what she was offering because it was a
cult power and you didn't have to be
morally good to get it and that's that's
why people go after that it's a power
that doesn't it doesn't require you to
give up carnal
desires right you just go all in for it
yeah so like in in in the
Chinese the original Yin and Yong which
I know are viewers you know we can see
that picture um there on screen the
original Yin and yangong was a circle
divided equally into light and dark
portions the dark portion had a little
bit of light in it and the light portion
had a little bit of dark in it that's
what the Dost say God is he's light and
darkness but we know that's not true
those symbols of the yin and yangong and
the hexagram and the schw all of them
have one meaning it is the union of
light and
darkness what they don't tell you is is
that light and darkness is actually
flesh and spirit that is exactly what
God wants he wants us to open our hearts
through surrender and obedience and
allow his Spirit to live inside of of
us that was probably the thing that that
really opened my eyes because I was
struggling after 24 almost 25 years of
doing this my mind had become blinded
and one night I was looking at all these
books that I had on martial arts and I
kept seeing this over and over again I
was like God yeah but this seems so
reasonable it seems scientific and the
Lord brought one verse 1 John 1 15 God
is light and in him is no Darkness at
all and it was like when that happened
it was like the wall of glass and
illusion just shattered it was like
praise him yeah I mean it was like the
light was just all through me and I was
like this is a lie I saw it after all
those years God we praise amen we're
starting to wind down here can you tell
our audience about the documentary yes
the documentary we did I think it was
released in 2014 we did it with little
light Studios it's a two- disk
documentary um the first disc I think is
available uh online and other places um
the second disc comes in a package when
you get that from Little Light Studios
well we thank God for your presence we
thank him for your experience turning
you around and using him for his glory
am we do actually have it on Dare To
Dream It's a special feature amen yes so
any closing thoughts for our audience I
would encourage everyone that's watching
right now know that God literally wants
to come inside of and live inside of you
Jesus wants to live inside of you
through his holy spirit if we allow God
to have access to our heart it's like in
Revelation 3: 20 it says I'm standing at
the door knocking if you'll hear my
voice and open the door that means
surrender and yield your will he says I
will come into you and Su with you and
you with me that is what God wants from
us more than anything else if we will
yield yield and surrender our will our
decisions to his and when you do that
there's Freedom unbelievable Freedom his
grace shall cover you and bless you amen
you're proof and testament to this and
the way that you said it just really
reminds me of the scripture when he says
deny yourself take up your cross and
follow me you've done that beautifully
thank you so much for being here thank
you for having me as you have learned
today there is no such thing as a
neutral spiritual experience you're
either yielding to spiritual Darkness or
the truth of Jesus Christ and his light
for an in-depth understanding please
check out the dragon revealed it's a
documentary available on Dare To Dream
we've only scratched the surface today
until next time please guard your
temples read your scripture share the
gospel with others Jesus is the light
the way and the truth I'm blessings win
and this has been a wolf in sheep's
clothing
[Music]
[Applause]